herrschaften ruhe bitte völkerkunde
heute geht zu beiden besonders krassen
fall von bipolarer störung der deutsche
in der fachliteratur auch bekannt als
die selbstgerechte umwelt sei der
katholische weltretter mit dem öko
siegel hält sich für den bewahrer der
schöpfung seitdem hinten an seinem suv
ein fahrrad angeschraubt hat den man
natürlich nie fern tatsächlich ist der
pkw das einzige familienmitglied wird
dass der deutsche noch echte gefühle
aufbringt seit einem aktuellen urteil
aus karlsruhe kann auto bei uns deshalb
auch offiziell als drittes geschlecht
eingetragen werden der deutsche ist im
prinzip für klima ist aber trotzdem rund
um die uhr tonnen von fleisch das geht
in ordnung wenn das futter aus dem
abgefackelten indonesischen regenwald
ein bios ticker hat das schwein vorher
eine patientenverfügung unterschreiben
mehrmals im jahr fliegt der deutschen
für 69 euro in ferne länder und erklärt
den doofen eingeborenen unser duales
system plastik und styropor kommen ins
meer und wertstoffe werden mitsamt den
gelben säcken verbannt weil es in
deutschland meistens kalt ist trägt der
öko blödmann eine fleecejacke
geschneidert aus recyceltem plastik
polen für rhabarber schorle und daher in
dem pflaster da müssen wir ein
grizzlybär im schritt wird er sie
täglich bei 90 grad in die waschmaschine
macht nichts es ja öko atomstrom aus
frankreich des deutschen liebster
fetisch aber ist die energiesparlampe
mit bewegungsmelder die würde sich am
liebsten die eigene rübe schrauben damit
dort ein licht land angeht wenn andere
sich bewegen wahrscheinlich einigt sich
deutschland am ende nur noch auf einen
beitrag zur klimarettung die
flächendeckende einführung der langen
unterhose zwischen oktober und april und
spart nicht nur fossile brennstoffe
sondern senkt nachweislich die
geburtenrate vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
unser kunde